on va passer au dos du jour je sais pas
si vous avez vu cette info terrible près
d'un Français sur TR c'est déjà privé de
repas faute de moyens euh donc à l'heure
où les le plein de courses au
supermarché de ça devient de plus en
plus compliqué hein Raymond nous en
parlait la dernière fois non mais c'est
vrai al l'heure où la fameuse
shrinkflation nous fait payer des
produits toujours plus cher pour moins
de quantité on a décidé ce soir dans
TPMP de vous donner tous les conseils
pour bien manger pas cher et pour ça on
a un spécialiste Norbert qui est avec
nous petit recéap et Norbert arrive
juste après Norbert arrière dépensez peu
j'ai bien 120 recettes originales pour
se régaler au quotidien en plus j'adore
Norbert donc c'est parfait c'est
parti en 2012 les téléspectateurs
découvrent Norbert un cuisinier drôle et
atypique sur lequel ils vont
immédiatement tomber sous le charme
c'est le John de la
cuisine 11 ans plus tard et alors que la
hausse des prix dans les supermarchés
frappe de plein fouet les Français qui
peent à joindre les debouts bah là par
exemple on est à 230 € ce qui est jamais
arrivé le chef vient de publier un
ouvrage dans lequel il explique comment
mieux mieux manger en dépensant moins
120 recettes qui vont vous permettre de
casser la routine du quotidien sans
exploser le budget alors comment manger
pour pas cher toutes les astuces de
Norbert ce soir dans
[Musique]
TPMP quel bonheur quel
bonheur quel bonheur de voir mon Norbert
que j'aime il le sait c'est un des gars
les plus sympathiques de la télévision
si ce n'est le plus sympathique juste
derrière Gilles
Verdez comment ça va mon orbert déjà
très bien et je suis content ça fait
longtemps mais ça fait longtemps tu
m'appelles plus plus rien tu m'as oublié
c'est fini bah non mais maintenant que
tu es champion de padle moi je moi je
suis le roi du couteau tu es le roi de
la raquette là comment tu sais très bien
que c'est toujours un bonheur comment ça
va qu'est-ce que tu fais alors
raconte-nous un peu ce que tu fais un
peu et ben qu'est-ce que je fais
aujourd'hui ben je suis venu parler de s
Ross chef de famille parce que je suis
papa et je m'occupe je fais à manger
pour mes quatre gosses donc je dis je
vais faire un livre pour les tous ceux
qui cuisinent pour leurs enfants et
leurs proches et la Bonne Nouvelle bah
ça va dans la continuité faire attention
à ce qu'on mange et pas trop cher je
suis dans les cuisines d'un célèbre
palace parisien
ouais et on va lancer le premier bistro
bouillon dans ce dans ce palace quel
Palace tu peux me le dire dans l'ORE
c'est le
prince le prince oui de Gal de G voilà
oui [__] bah j'ai ramené pour vous
d'ailleurs le sushi il est Chambé là-bas
je te remercie je fais pas encore des
sushis pour vous
VO
làbas qué attends et ça c pour donc je
remercie chef pâtissière hlè voilà vous
avez fait ça c'est tout ce que vous
allez retrouver sur le CH dessert c'est
magnifique
ça allez on fait des échanges allez y a
pas de jaloux des madeleines voilà on
échange la Bour d'Alou hop
là c'est quoi vous que j'ai mis des
cuillères ah merde j'ai mis des
cuillères oh là là tenez allez part
tout servi je pas
ven je ou
pasz
quoi je dis quand Mme merci carlogen qui
la chef pâtissière parce qu'elle a fait
çaourog
alors mon n merci c'est un bonheur de te
voir c'est hyper bon c'est extra alors
là vous goûtez en avant-première C en
avant-première vous goûtez le charot de
dessert qu'on va faire donc dans ce
fameux Palace bistro et on annonce tout
le monde parce qu'on parle de prix hein
c'est bien là on parle de ça ce soir on
fait un menu à 49 € entrée plat dessert
ouais et on commencera par un premier
plat à l'ardoise dans ce bistr moulefrit
ah Gal metsmoi cl moules
voilà super bon merci merci
Cyril bah Norbert on est alors Norbert
les 10 astuces pour manger bien et pas
cher oui un cuisiner soi-même super bon
ouais cuisiner soi-même c'est à la
cuisine c'est un peu comme le sport
c'est un peu comme la musique c'est un
peu comme tous les il faut s'entraîner
il faut s'entraîner et plus on
s'entraîne plus on va vite et plus on
exécute correctement donc c'est faire
soi-même c'est commencer par déjà
peut-être faire des pâtes déjà déjà
c'est faire des bonnes pâtes mais des
bonnes pâtes fraîes sais que c'est pas
évident faire des bonnes pâtes ah des
bonnes pâes fraîches il paraît dit ne
pas se contenter des grandes surfaces
non non on se contente pas des grandes
surfaces on peut aujourd'hui et ça
devient un loisir aujourd'hui on a plein
de fermes autour de Paris je parle de
Paris et à la banlieu et on peut sortir
et on peut aller viter des fermes où il
y a des animaux où on peut acheter sur
place des des fruits des légumes et on
peut justement c'est pédagogique et en
plus quand je dis ça c'est surtout la
très bonne idée de notre gouvernement en
ce moment d'en parler de remettre la
cuisine à l'école c'est ce qu'a dit
Olivier Grégoire et moi je trouve ça
intéressant parce que moi-même je je
suis pas là à l'école et je pense je
pense que si j'avais eu de la cuisine à
l'école ça m'aurait donné envie
d'apprendre la géographie l'histoire
voir où on va chercher un poisson par
exemple voyez quand j' quand j'entends
que au Pays-Bas qu'on va trouver du
saumon il y a un problème voyez voilà
donc le saumon ça se trouve où dans
l'eau vous voulez un petit truc à
[Rires]
boire et donc parre des petites casses
en Cu faut me les ramener j'en ai pas
beaucoup c'est délicieux
heors tu dis aussi acheter les produits
de base acheter des produits de baseah
produit de base on s'en sert même dans
les restaurants du lait de la farine du
beurre des ufs et on fait tout avec ça
du sel du sucre et on a tout ce qu'il
faut comment Pat voà par exemple si
j'avais des ufs et du lait je vous
aurais fait une petite crème
anglaise vous allez le manger tout
seulou pas tu dis qu'il faut revenir au
plat traditionnel après je lu pas dit
que j'ais envoyé la facture production
mais me fais pas ça s'il te
plaît enain de se
régaler qu' faut revenir au plat
traditionnel ouais bien sûr c'est quoi
les plat traditionnel c'est les les
plats en fait de nos grand-mères qui
coûtent pas cher ça coûte pas cher une
blanquette de veau ça coûte pas cher
ouisar au beur l'arr au
beur c'est quoi le plat le moins cher le
plat le moins cher le moin cher le moins
cher c'est aujourd'hui pomme de terre UF
ouis pomme de terre œuf aujourd'hui les
œufs il faut compter à peu près une
siseuf c'est à peu près entre 1,65 et 2
€ les ciseufs frais vous avez la farine
on est à 1,65 environ et donc avec ça
vous faites déjà des pâtes vous faites à
manger pour pas mal de monde et après
les légumes bien sûr les protéines
végétales comme nous on l'appelle dans
notre métier bah c'est moins cher le
poireau la carotte le navet revenir à
tout ça vous pouvez faire des bouillons
et voilà non mais qui est bien c'est
qu'en lui donnant le fondant je peux
parler laisser les tes tu dis acheter
des produits de saison ça paraî bête oui
il parait qu' faut faire une tomate
achetée en plein hiver coûtera plus cher
puis qu' plus lo bah en fait le
producteur lui va faire des poireaux il
va faire 22 tonnes de poireau si vous
lui demander de la tomate forcément la
production elle s'arrête parce que la
saison elle s'arrête donc forcément vous
allez avoir beaucoup plus d'énergie pour
préer de la tomate sous ser ou la faire
venir en import et forcément là vous
payez plus cher j'ai une question ça va
pouvez faire tourner le brony s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
ou touche pas ça touche pas à
ça on en a plein il faut préparer s vous
plaît pré mené men bah les menus en fait
c'est ce qui va vous aider aujourd'hui à
à mieux vous organiser et à faire les
courses ouais il y a plein de gens qui
des fois sont pris sont pris au dernier
moment ils vont faire les courses et ils
achètent comme ça et en fait de faire
des menus de prévoir c'est ce qui vous
permettra de mieux faire vos budget
votre budget savoir ce que vous allez
manger et surtout bah préparer en avance
quand on fait les courses quand on
achète du poisson on va le manger au
début de la semaine et non pas en plein
milieu parce qu' il va Dober sinon ça
mais pas jeter parce que parfois on
achète plein de trucs au supermarché
puis on se rend compte qu' on l'a pas
mangé puis la date est passée on le
jette moi j'ai déjàeté les poulets
entiers alors là petite réponse à ça
vous avez une technique on a appris il y
a très longtemps si une viande commence
un peu à poquer hein n'hésitez pas à
faire un bain d'eau avec du sel mettre
un peu de thint et d'ail ça s'appelle
une saumure vous rincez cette viande
sous l'eau et vous la plongez une
demi-heure une heure dedans et après
vous allez pouvoir la récupérer c'est ce
qu'on fait en charcuterie pour pour
garder la viande on appelle ça de la
saumure et on conserve la il y a moins
de risque après vous savez quand vous
aller en Afrique du Nord les viandes
elles sont archi cuites donc faites
pareil cuisez la viande ne faites pas
une viande bleue si elle est un peu elle
est un peu passé mais bienite ça passera
a moins de risque d'être contaminé alors
tu dis euh un autre conseil ne pas
craindre le surgeler ouais ouais le
surgelé écoutez si je dois choisir moi
je le dis aux gens si vous devez choisir
entre une boîte une boîte de conserve et
du surgelé dans la boîte de conserve
pour conserver le produit il faut un
liquide une saumure et le produit en
fait il va se détériorer tandis que le
froid on cueille où on prend on fait le
produit on le met directement en froid
donc on va le bloquer donc les légumes
sont gelés c'est mieux que les
conservesou bien sûr parce qu'en fait
prenez une boîte de petit poid en
conserve vous allez voir le petit Po est
délavé et il perd son goût d'accord dès
que vous le prenez surgelé vous avez
plus soit il est déjà cuit soit vous le
plongez dans l'eau vous avez plus qu'à
maîtriser la cuisson et et surtout
pardon NORB il y a aussi du sucre et du
sel dans les boîtes de conserv qu' a pas
dans le surgelé exactement c'est très
important parce que c'est le sucre caché
question surgeler si je cuisine rôti je
congèle combien de temps combien de
temps je vous dirais plutôt de le
surgeler cru accru mais si vous vous le
surgelez cuit il faut quand même le
repasser au four oui mais combien de
temps on peut garder ça mettant un mois
de bah en fait le congélateur c'est pas
une boîte c'est pas une boîte magique
mais on va commencer aussi à à le
produit va se désagréger mais en tout
cas vous perdez pas le produit
directement mais vous vous le gardez un
mois ou deux au congèle après vous le
ressortez vous le passez vous le passez
au four et puis c'est très bien voilà il
y a pas une recette avec laarign
[Rires]
banane là là faut mettre directement à
la [__] dans le congèle et là là elle
reste bien
dur on passe pass
bon moi limite non mais limite limite
limite je préférais l'ning du
gars alors il faut faire gaffe aux
promotions oui les promotions faut faire
attention parce que des fois on a des
promotions sur des produits qui sont pas
excessivement de bonne qualité ouis et
il faut mieux acheter en plus petite
quantité c'est vrai même quand on a faim
que d'acheter vraiment des promotions où
le produit par exemple le poulet il a
pas vu le jour du tout on sait même pas
il sait même pas qu'il a existé le
poulet et on fait des promotions sur ça
et et c'est pas toujours évident donc
faut pas tronquer aussi le consommateur
par vous pouvez demander moi ce que je
conseille aux gens c'est d'aller sur les
fins de marché et les commerçants font
des prix et ça c'est intéressant même
j'ai vu des commerçants dernièrement à
plutôt où ils mettent directement le
prix sur le papier le papier craft et
vous avez directement le prix de la
portion 6 balles 4 balles et ça je salue
les commerçants parce que eux pour le
coup ils mettent vraiment en danger leur
commerce mais ils le font quand même
pour pas jeter donc ils mettent des prix
au rabetis à la fin du marché voilà
c'est le fin la fin de marché fin de
marché pas la fin de boîte de nuit comme
fa non c'est pas les mêmes produits
exactement ce sont pas les mêmes
produits il faut fa également bien
ranger son frigo ça je le dis chaque
année je le dis chaque année non mais
c'est vrai faut bien ranger son frigo
chaque étage mais ouais parce que ça ça
sert à quoi au moins on voit ce qu'on a
exactement non mais c'est vrai bah en
fait ça permet de voir surtout et de
ranger la nourriture mais de savoir
aussi ce qu'on peut consommer quand
c'est le bazar on entasse et surtout
c'est les boîtes quand vous mettez des
boîtes devant bah des produits qui sont
plus petits vous les voyez pas vous les
prenez pas et vous faites pas attention
et surtout après ça ça vous donne plus
envie de cuisiner vous êtes fatigué vous
avez des journées compliquées là quand
c'est quand même assez ordonné vous
allez vite et vous comprenez vite ce
qu'il faut faire bien sûr voilà
oui non mais c'est vrai c'est une bonne
idée parce que moi mon frigo c'est un
bordel sans nom qu'estce qu' s fout ah
d'accord pardon excusez-moiter une
anecdote une anecdote sur ton frigo
est-ce que est-ce que
par non non j'avais
terminé est-ce que c'est bien par
exemple pour un gain de temps de le
dimanche faire tous les repas de la
semaine et après les mettre sous vide
avec une machine de sous vide alors ça
c'est une vraie question et j'en parle
de plus en plus c'est un investissement
et moi je pense que là pour le coup on
pourrait avoir une aide de l'État pour
tout le monde c'est que la machine sousv
alors ça c'est du vacum c'est qu'on
extrait l'air à travers mais la machine
sousv et on a un thermoplongeur ça c'est
cuisinier donc ça existe depuis
longtemps ça coûte pas très cher vous
mettez cette sonde avec le thermomètre
et vous chauffez l'eau vous mettez sous
vide et vous cuisez vous pouvez tout
cuire en même temps et conserver plus
longtemps sans avoir une déperdition de
de de protéin ou de on perd pas les
nutriment alors boî comme ça c'est plus
écolo encore non oui c'est très bien et
en plus vous voyez ce qu'il y a dedans
généralement moi chez moi j'ai j'ai ce
défaut là j'ai des boîtes opaques je
vois pas toujours et on n pas
toujours exactement exactement et enfin
il faut aussi investir dans des boîtes
en vert ouais c'est ça derrière vous non
mais voulez un petit
fondant les aliments peu chers et sains
les légumes pas chers les brocolis les
carottes les pommes de terre les patates
douces tomates chou potiron oignons
fruits pas chers pommes banane orange
poire ananas Clémentine
ouais les légumineuses les lentill
haricots je
déteste
lentill bet sportif la mais la protéine
que ça
vous Mang ma mère fait ce qu'on appelle
de la tu vois c'est avec la lentilles
c'est des pâtes avec des lentilles
ça'appelle tu
ve d'accord ouais mais après tu peux
faire deux matchs d'affilé là-dessus
ouais je sais je sais je sais il y a
poisson en conserve Sardin thon et macro
c'est très bon qu non macro je peux pas
arrête pourquoi c'est super bon tout ce
qui est bon pour ton sport tu le prends
pas et je sais je déteste le macro et le
macro à la moutard une sardine quo le
macro à la moutarde bon c'est bon après
je vous conseille moi de vous faire
vous-même il y a des très bonnes
moutardes aussi ça c'est pareil on a
vécu une pénurie de moutarde c'est que
les moutardes dans les industriells il y
a de l'huile la vraie moutarde il y a
pas d'huile d'huile bien sûr dans le
bouquin d'ailleurs vous expliquez
comment faire toutes les sauces he c'est
exement vous avez le B àas vous avez 30
pas à pas en photo comment faire une
pâte à brioche sans robot faire une pâte
à pizza faire des pâtes vous-même et
dedans je démocratise même de fait que
celui qui peut pas aller acheter des des
marchés des produits de haute qualité il
peut aller au centre commercial même
dans les discounters et se faire plaisir
alors le macro c'est bon tu trou ah oui
super bon c'est super bon
Emmanuel bravo non non non c'est
horrible je te jure j'en ai jamais mangé
je déteste ça vousz mangest ça m'inspire
pas confiance les ufs il faut des poules
élevé en plein air ou pas des poules
voilà en batterie batterie batterie
exactement et les produits laitiers non
pasteurisés que tu as dit ou oui les
céréales riz complet avoine pâte complè
SAR rasin et maïs très bon exactement
viande blanche poulet entier cuiss de
poulet blanc de dinde ça c'est important
ça c'est fort ça ça c'est important
exactement bravo bravo bravo il y a
combien de rebonds au badle là vous
savez combien de rebonds estce que je
vous ai je vous ai vu jouer là mais un
rebond c'est tout mais ça tape partout
c'est du squash en fait non bah tu
viendras ok viendra qu'une boîte de
macro mais vraiment e en revanche
Norbert c'était extraordinaire ce que tu